for for
[Silence]
asalam alikum
as
[Silence]
h
Allah
[Silence]
alhamdulillah
subhana for
[Silence]
my dear brothers respected Elders
mothers and sisters we thank Allah
subhana tala for keeping us alive one
more day on the path of Islam on the
and allowing me and you to enter his
house and worship him in the manner that
pleases him I ask Allah subhana to
accept from me and accept from you the
little we do in his path a mean and I
bear witness there is no deed worthy of
worship except for Allah subhana wa tala
and Prophet Muhammad sallallah alai was
is his last and final messenger for
surely who Allah subhana tala choose to
guide nson can misguide and whoever
choose to misguide n guide him back to
the path and we seek refuge in Allah
from darkness of our ourselves and evil
of our Deeds for Allah is all knowing
and all seeing what his creation
does
alhamdulillah the Islamic new year has
started and we had a about that and
traditionally in the western culture
when a new year begins people will like
to do some kind of accountability and
set up some goals for them eles to
perform better in that
year what I to say or what I like
to personally actually tell myself and
what I to do is not having
goals setting up a goal is setting
yourself up for failure in a sense stay
with me
though I believe we should have mild
markers in our
lives what happens is when you have a
goal and you hit that goal or you reach
that goal that job is
completed you know my job is to get a
bachelor's degree that's my goal in
life what happens when I get the
bachelor
degree the goal is done it's over
now education and learning and a
betterment of oneself should be a
lifelong Mission and for that lifelong
Mission setting up goals is is setting
yourself up for possible failures we
to have Milestones set
up when you and I travel from Tucson to
Phoenix how many times is it that
somebody in the car you know if you are
blessed of not having kids and I say
that you know in the other way blessing
you don't get to hear are we there
yet
no and then literally 5 minutes pass
so are we there no I just told you
no no no but I want to know and then
what do you do you tell them oh we are
65 Mi away from Phoenix we're now 55 mil
away from Phoenix we're 80 Mi away from
Phoenix whatever this this might be and
I'm going backwards I know I went
backwards it's okay maybe you stopped at
the rest area for 15 20 minutes and that
delayed you further you know but
whatever it is you have a mile marker on
the highway that tells you what have you
progressed how far have you gotten along
and as Muslims we need to have a mile
marker and we need to have a retrospect
an inspection of ourselves every single
time there is a significant event and I
say that a significant event because
starting of the new year of the hij 1445
that means we are that closer to end of
time we're that closer to rest of our
lives being one year
less the time is
passing I don't know and you don't know
when would it be a last breath maybe I
will not get to lead Salah
Allah we don't know
that so those mild markers that we're
passing in our life are we getting
better or are we getting worse and one
of the things that we should as Muslims
be looking at ourselves is the main
thing in my personal opinion and and if
somebody has a disagreement please come
and see me afterwards is the betterment
of our character
now hear with me and stay with me on
this
topic theam mentions
explicitly he
says I was sent not but only to perfect
the character of the human
being I said this last week we were
talking about something a brother was in
my office and he has advised on a
different matter and this topic came up
and W this is a topic that pains me
every single time we talk about
it the fasting was there
before wasam got the prophet
Hood some form
of Salah was still present
some form of IM in Allah was still
present and the Haj of B was still being
established we're not going to go into
details of what form it was but it was
still being
done every single thing we have was
there in some form or shape
beforeall got Prophet hood and if you
read this Hadith in that context I was
not sent except to per
the characteristic or the character of
the human
being when when the sahaba have migrated
to Haba and Nashi calls them the famous
spece that is made he says what the the
the sahabi says we were the worst of the
people we
killed our
daughters we did all the possible we
stole land and we killed each other for
no
reason this is part of his famous speech
that he
says to explain what they have learned
when they entered
Islam
today we see and we talk to brothers and
sisters who cry for festine and so
rightfully
be the slaughter of innocent should be
mourned every every single day every
single time of any Muslim
life Allah subh says the the killing of
one innocent Muslim life is enough for
the whole world to destroy itself
over rightfully so but bear with me and
hear me out on this matter what one
happens when we are taking the property
and the rights of another Muslim in our
family where are the tears then
how bad do we feel
then are we are verbally abusing people
around us where are
your honors
then it is okay to
take the the the land of the
poor and still say muham I'm I'm Muslim
says
Muslim a Muslim is a brother of a Muslim
he does not degreg him denigrate him he
does not show him
lower
theam was he was the toughest on
himself and he had the most leeway for
the
others some of this community members
went for Hajj and you talk to them and
you figure out how much stress and
anxiety and turmoil and and fatigue it
is and is on and people are coming to
him
in I cut my hair off before I did
the he pi the look at the books of the
of the of the of
the he's saying it don't worry about it
it's okay don't worry about it it's
okay you go to to spend one
night's routine was that he
prayed every
night he prayed so long that his feet
would swell
up but he guessed to mif and he purposed
chooses to rest because he knew that his
umah would have a hard time to stay up
that night in so say you pray the all
your life alhamdulillah when you get to
M sleep that night cuz that night is
meant for rest from sahu alaih wasallam
and we what do we do as Muslims we take
out the
most for
ourselves brother you brother you know
there's a Hadith for this
okay and then you see somebody else
brother what's wrong with you well hold
on time out a minute ago you you had a
Hadith for yourself there's no Hadith
for your brother
now what happened
there hold yourself to a higher
accountability than you do anybody
else and that's
the that's the way of the
prophethood that's the way of
prophethood to make ease for people to
make ease for
people to create ease for them you know
a lot of times when the when the IM is
leading Salah on the the is to read you
know in the second have you paid
attention what the topic is towards the
end of the Surah
Allah subh is talking
to and remind them for you are a person
who
reminds remind the remind the people
because you are a person who reminds
folks literal definition or translation
of this Ayah on under under one
translation in English translation it
literally said do not be a dictator upon
them literally said the
words meaning
what you cannot hold that stick on the
folks and start beating them up with
that have we
forgotten the story that we have about
the the the Ramadan of
am you know Ramadan is not even
beginning yet and we Muslims
alhamdulillah around the world are in a
rush what time is what time is we're
going to do we're going to finish the
Quran what's happening what's
happening did not come out of the house
for the third night he stayed inside and
the house is if you've been to M
alhamdulillah if you've not may Allah
take you and show you the Blessed
SES
where is that was his house that was the
that's where he was and the Masid is
right there's not literally if I had to
exaggerate from this member to that
pillar that's how the far the member
ofam is from his door W without
exaggeration people are outside he can
hear them they're talking amongst
themselves they're knocking the
door come pray he does not come out F he
comes out he said I heard you all I
heard the knocks on the door I heard the
complaint
why did you come I did not want Allah to
make it mandatory on my and the umah
would not be able to perform that
Salah and today alhamdulillah we have
chips to give out you know most of you
if you grew up in a big city you know
what a parking mate is you don't one
brother's laughing you don't have that
in Tucson man I grew up in New York City
we had parking mates and you know when
they walked out they used to have a
stack that big orange looking tickets
two second Runing it and you getting it
and they'll stand in front of your car
and block you from leaving and look I'm
leave no I already started riding stop
and I can't stop riding we walk out with
that booklet every day to give out
fatwas to people oh you didn't pray huh
this was Ramadan I didn't see you
for you know you're not a good
person now
can any one of us
guarantee the the condition we're going
to die in
no the time is flying by and I got
several other things to cover inshallah
so I'm going to try to speed up a little
bit I want to mention this this story of
of an Arabi who comes
to and he says
he says count to me the characteristics
of do you know how to count my brother
he's an Arabi he's meaning that he comes
from far away places right they're
usually not educated I'm not saying that
present day I'm talking about General we
stereotyping he says yes yes of course I
know to count SOI tells him to count for
him the blessings of the world and he
says I can't
I'm I can't count the blessings in the
world so looks at him and he
says he looks at him you know surprised
he says you can't count the blessing of
the and when Allah subh
says the the blessing on this world is
very
few and you're telling me you can't
count that and you're asking me to count
the character of the
Prophet when Allah subh says in the
Quran
you are at the highest
character at the highest
character and this is what we need to
reflect upon let me close the first
sermon with the story
of is a huge name in the
sahaba huge name there's a narration
mentioned and there's a couple different
names mentioned but the narration I me
mentioned used to say if Allah subh
asked me who I left behind for his umah
I would say I left behind
M and that would be sufficient for the
umah is leading the
prayers a man who lives outside of
Medina comes to join the Salah
and starts reading the joke amongst are
when somebody asks you to read a short
Salah you read I'm just joking it's
okay don't worry don't worry no no we're
going to keep it
short is
reading the man stands behind him and
after a while he breaks his Salah he
goes to the side he Praises Salah and he
leaves mu finds out from some people
there are some Whispers And there he's
told that the man came broke his Salah
his Salah separately and then departed M
said he
is not a
Muslim right in a sense he's a
maaf in a sense that he's a hypocrite
he's not a good
person the story reaches the man that mu
has called you aaf the man gets
toam and he goes to the to theam he says
mu has called me this and he tells the
story that we are day laborers we wake
up early in the morning and we go far
off to work and we slave away all day
and we come home at night and now it's
time for to rest because we have to wake
up early and again and go out and do the
work again and was leading a long
Salah and I could not anymore stand
there so I left the Salah prayed my own
Salah and went
back no
problems
calls and he says this is the words ofth
brothers this is not my words
please oh are you starting a f in
the what is wrong with you what have you
done
now why can't you
read and if you if you listen to
Scholars they say F can be longer and
then is should be a moderate Salah it
shouldn't be too long because people
have to retire to bed this is the words
of to
who
which is saying that if Allah asked me
who I left behind for
the I will say I left behind m
this is the character of the as this is
the character of of sahab this is the
character
ofat I ask Allah subhana to give us
the to have some interest back and have
the thought
process to go through and fix our
characters and soften our tongues and
soften our hearts for our fellow
brothers and sisters
[Silence]
alhamdulillah if I can request your
brothers to move forward those empty
spaces in front of you take those empty
spots and adjust your sitting patterns
please move forward please if you could
we're almost to the door so let's like
to have a little more space in the back
for those Brothers they joining us
later inah
[Silence]
says I heard Prophet Muhammad s alai
wasallam
says facil facilitate things to people
concerning their religious
matters make it easier for the folks to
follow the de and do not make hard for
them and give
them and give them good glad tidings or
give them good news and do not make them
run away from
Islam this is the Crux of our religion
is
today W if you if you have to take an
accountability of how long the Muslims
have been amongst non-muslims and the
reason those people are not attracted to
Dean or to our
religion I probably will have to boil it
down to one main thing and that's this
right
here we we do not have a good
characteristics we don't have a good
character in a sense that we are not
following the prophetic path
of our tongues have not
softened our hearts have not
softened we are
more tough on people than we are on
ourselves you
know a lot of times I see people who
take the shahada and accept Islam and
it's literally their first 10
minutes and then somebody has to give
him a lecture on how they have to
memorize the suras and brother take a
deep
breath this just only been 10 minutes
you have to give some breather to the
brother
he's trying to
learn when you were born alhamdulillah
most of us born to Muslim household even
you didn't learn the first time you read
the
Surah even today there's a lot of things
that we do that we have not understood
properly in our religion so if Allah
subhana is for you why isn't to somebody
else let me finish with this
story and this the True Story by the way
and I can relate with this story because
I was once a young man
too because I I went through the same
torture as this person had gone through
one of my sh mentioned a story of a
young man who took shahada and became
Muslim and the man had long
hair a young man had long hair took a
shahada went to the Masjid I see some of
you smiling already they already know
where it's going he went to the Masjid
and and he was told Haram brother you
have long
hair now now I want you to hear this
part clearly the man went home ashamed
and had a debate with himself should he
leave Islam now or should he continue to
practice this is a new Muslim so he
debates himself and he comes to the
conclusion okay you know what is just
here I will stick with my
religion and Allah gued him because
nobody else could have guided that at
that point he stays with his religion
and he shaves his head literally shaves
his head completely
bald and he said you know he came back
to Mid and he tried to reconnect and he
said after some time passed he started
to to want to learn
the and he said you know to my amazement
when I read the SE ofam I found out Alam
had long hair
I pose a question to you and you can
answer it to yourself you don't have to
answer it to me if that person had left
his Dean that day who would have been
responsible on a day of in front of
Allah
subh
so have the highest measurement stick
for
yourself and then the shortest stick for
everybody else around you
have the the the the and the and all of
that for for others in your life not for
yourself and offer them
that may Allah subh make us a pure umah
in the meanings of the pure umah and may
Allah subh remove the hatred from our
heart for each other as and our brothers
and our sisters and may Allah subh make
us all a guiding path and a Shining
Light to those who want to come to the
Deen of
Islam and may Allah subh make us from
the people who tongues are soft and the
hearts are even softer and may Allah
make us from the folks who are uniting
and not dividing umah and make Allah
make us from the people that when we
meet Allah subhana tala we can proudly
say that if we did not do anything else
at least our tongues were the softest
with
theat and we tried to copy his
characters as best as we
[Silence]
can for
Allah
[Silence]
Str your minds full the gaps
between may Allah have mercy upon usen
alhamd
[Silence]
Aman for
allahar
[Silence]
Allah
abbar Allah abbar
[Silence]
allahar
allahar ald
[Silence]
Aman
be
[Silence]
allahar
allahar allahar
[Silence]
allahar
Allah Allah my
[Silence]
asay
it was here yeah that's all
I almost feel it should be back
here literally about here you walk
up